des scènes d'affrontements parfois d'une
extrême violence
sous le regard impuissant des forces de
l'ordre israéliennes depuis plusieurs
jours des villes mixtes en israël sont
le théâtre d'importantes tensions
communautaires épicentre du phénomène la
ville de lod
situé à quelques kilomètres de tel aviv
d'un côté des juifs ultranationalistes
de l'autre des arabes israéliens
chacun s'accuse ans d'être à l'origine
des provocations après les trois
dernières soirées nous ne sortions plus
nous savions que nous ne pouvions pas
sortir parce que les arabes étaient là
ils se rassembler en groupes et
commencer à nous jeter des pierres et à
brûler nos affaires les colons sont
venus vers les habitations et ont cassé
des fenêtres ils ont essayé de rentrer
ils ont fait peur à ma femme et à mes
enfants
ils ont brûlé les voitures ici pour
tenter de contenir la violence dans la
ville
et face aux stigmates encore visibles
des heurts de ces derniers jours
comme cette synagogue qui a été incendié
les autorités israéliennes ont annoncé
le déploiement de renforts massifs dans
les villes mixtes du pays l'état
d'urgence a également été décrété à lod
mais signe que la fracture est profonde
il n'ya pas seulement ces affrontements
il y a aussi des agressions ciblées sur
ces images de vidéosurveillance un juif
est attaquée à jérusalem
ici une foule d'ultranationalistes
lynchage chauffeur arabe dans une
banlieue de tel aviv
la scène a été diffusé en direct à la
télévision
une situation d'anarchie
selon les mots du premier ministre
israélien benyamin nétanyahou qu'il
qualifie même de deuxième front après
celui qui oppose israël au hamas aux
citoyens d'israël jeudi que je me fiche
que votre sang bouillonne vous ne pouvez
pas vous faire justice vous même vous ne
pouvez pas venir et prendre un citoyen
arabe et essayer de le lyncher
tout comme on ne peut pas voir des
citoyens arabes faire cela des citoyens
juifs à lod
un peu plus d'un tiers des habitants de
cette ville moyenne et arabes cela fait
des décennies qu'il cohabite de manière
relativement paisible avec leurs
concitoyens juifs au gré des conflits
mais depuis plusieurs années cette ville
pauvre a vu arriver de plus en plus de
sionistes religieux alors la menace
d'expulsion de palestiniens à jérusalem
est a ravivé la crainte qui existent
aussi dans cette ville du centre
d'israël
résultats des groupes souvent jeunes se
radicaliser s'affrontent
la situation inquiète les autorités
politiques et religieuses et malgré les
appels au calme répéter les discours
belliqueux du hamas et de netanyahu ont
des répercussions très directe dans les
rues des villes mixtes israélienne